[Music]
so what do you make about sort of the
general state of religion altogether not
not just Judaism but the general state
of religion in America in 2017 I mean by
those polls we see in America yeah the
amount of non-believers is right rolling
tremendously atheist growing
tremendously I think Jedi's up there
which I'm okay with that one do you do
sense that religion as an institution is
weakening in America I think I like the
way you ask the questions because the
question because I think what is
weakening our institutions I think
institutions in general don't have the
appeal that they once did people don't
want to sit in buildings and pray they
want to go out they want to be on
mountaintops they want to be on hikes I
think the feeling that religion speaks
to is not lessening but I think that the
organization and the institution speaks
less to people than it once did going to
do about that as a rabbi you got a nice
big building I think it's right exactly
well actually it's funny because I just
I have an article coming out this week
in the Los Angeles Jewish Journal about
writing about about taking services
outside part of the reason is that I
think that especially younger people
don't feel connected to the buildings
that they didn't build after all the
generation before them built this
building feel great about it but but
they inherited it so what you do about
it I think is you reconfigure religion
and when I said earlier that I didn't
know what Judaism would look like in a
hundred years my assumption was that it
will look different and one of the ways
that it'll look different is I suspect
that it will reintegrate into the
natural world in a way that we haven't
so far in at least in America and and I
don't what do you mean by that I mean
that that the the idea of of worship in
nature and the idea not a worship of
nature but worship in nature the idea of
meditation and alternative ways of
connecting to the Jewish tradition and
using the learning of the Jewish
tradition to open as opposed to to only
have narrower community
these will become a greater and greater
trend so you will have probably two
different kinds of Jewish communities
ones that are more self-sufficient and
more institution based and others that I
think are looser and broader something
like the sort of Orthodox ones that you
referenced earlier they'll they'll keep
all that sort of older stuff I think
although there are challenges to
orthodoxy that's going to be very hard
for the community to and the principal
ones are the challenge of the position
of women which is a constant issue in
the Orthodox community and inclusion
LGBT to inclusion which is also a
challenge to the Orthodox community yeah
so we're in LA you said I could ask you
anything yes I see these ultra-orthodox
guys out there it's a hundred degrees
yes in Los Angeles now they're wearing a
big wool coat right a big wool hat this
can't be what God wants come on
well walking down Wilshire the reason
that wearing well then so you have all
these ornate yes exactly
that's the point the point is that that
dress wasn't originally Jewish dress it
was the dress of Polish nobleman in the
19th century which is why as a
conservative Jew I say history clearly
affects the way Jews practice but at a
certain point people who are if not
conservative and reactionary what they
what they tend to do is they pick a
period in history which is the ideal
period and they try to recreate that
period over and over and over and over
and over again wherever they are
wherever they go like the clock has
stopped it's a strategy that works in
some ways but I think in other ways is
unproductive so all right is that fair
enough you mentioned LGBT community that
you were for gay marriage what like
something like years ago yeah years ago
before before it was legal right here
yeah how did your congregation take it
did you have to take counsel with other
rabbis to show you wanted well the
atheistic cetera I mean the uproar was
so great in my congregation that when I
announced that I was going to do gay
marriages it would literally was on the
front page of the New York and the LA
Times
that's how upheaval --is-- to coin a
phrase it was there were a lot of people
matter - it was legal in California but
not right legally right but not yet
legal and what was before the Supreme
Court decision my congregation and I had
waited until I thought it wouldn't split
my congregation apart my congregation
was many I mean many people were very
supportive I don't want to paint with
too broad a brush many were very upset
part of the reason that many were upset
is not only because some were
conservative but also I think there were
some I again don't want to paint with
too broad a brush but I have Mike McAra
Gatien about half from Iran and many who
had emigrated from Iran for them this
was a giant cultural shift that they
really didn't like so for me it was here
was that here was sort of the contrast
that I was struck with I knew that it
was going to be I didn't know it was
going to be quite as big as it turned
out to be I knew it was going to be big
and I prepared it I taught a series of
classes and so on and then I wrote a
letter about why I was doing it and
before I sent it out I wanted my
daughter to know she was at the time I
guess about 15 14 or 15 I wanted her to
know because she was going to hear stuff
and I she went to a school with a lot of
people from the congregation and I
thought people might say bad things
about me and I wanted her to know what I
was doing so I said Samara I said I just
want you to know I'm sending this letter
out to the congregation to say that I'm
going to start doing same-sex marriages
and she looked at me strangely and she
said what took you so long and I rely
said yes that's the point the point is
that this is a huge generational shift
the biggest one I think maybe humanity
has ever seen in one generation from the
people for whom it was really
inconceivable was like I was saying I
was going to marry Martians they
couldn't imagine how a rabbi could even
think of doing such a thing to someone
who said well I was like I was saying to
her I'm now going to marry people who
are blonde the people who are redhead
right so it was incredible so I'm
curious
well first of its strikes me that you're
in a particularly unique situation
because generally American Jews are
liberal your action you're in a
congregation in Los Angeles we tried to
come on the west side of Los Angeles
that is not liberal and your client's
not liberal that sort of like just a
fascinating it is inside or mixed you
need to what you're sort of dealing with
there so when I've had other people on
that that have argued from a Jewish
perspective when we talk about marriage
so when I've had been Shapiro and Dennis
Prager on and we've talked about this
kind of dance
both of them have basically got it to
the point of saying they're not really
for it but that this is where they're
libertarianism sort of takes over so
just get the state out of it and I don't
care I yours doesn't seem to come from
that no no no I think that that's I I
don't let me just put it this way
without itself every individual I don't
approve of that point of view and I
don't and I don't honestly have a great
deal of admiration for it
well I not just for the government
should be a religion or government
should be out of your right to marry and
that's that well because they because
the only reason that they're saying that
they didn't feel that ten years ago the
only reason that they're saying that is
because the cultural backlash against
saying you know the government shouldn't
do that is too great so I think that
they're being forced into a more moral
position but it's not because they
advocated and if you think that it's
okay for if you think that people
shouldn't do it then don't say people
shouldn't they wouldn't say that about
abortion I mean if you really think that
there's a moral issue here then stand up
for the moral issue and make a case for
it for the record I basically said that
because I because I think there is a
moral issue here and the moral issue
here is that when someone comes to me
and says it's not you know the the other
day there was a there was a cover story
on this said about about people who've
come out in the gay community in the
Orthodox community and how they're
struggling with it and and as I read
through it I just thought there's not
enough of an acknowledgement that your
sexual identity it's fundamental to who
you are it just is it's not like the
clothes you wear it's not you
know that I don't like mushrooms it's
not I'm a vegetarian it's not merely as
fundamental to me right as my sexual
identity right so when someone comes to
you and says this is how I was born this
is how God made me and if it's not
whatever connection of genetics or I
didn't choose this is who I am and
you're telling me that in the Jewish
tradition there is no place for me to
express my love to the only kind of
people that I can love this way who can
say no to that I mean who can say I'm
sorry but you have to put away who you
are because there's a verse in Leviticus
so I think a lot of people are going to
be watching this beer and other
non-believers but some people who are
believers of whatever and they won't
like this but oh I was going to say the
reverse I think they're gonna say holy
[ __ ] I've been waiting for someone why I
say that I mean look some of the most
moving experiences that I've had have
been a result of this in fact the most I
have to say this this sounds very
strange but it doesn't didn't sound
strange to me the most romantic moment I
have ever seen at a wedding was the
first wedding I did between two men and
and I can tell you I mean they taped to
the whole thing I'm sure that they will
know won't identify it but one of them
turned to the other they decided they
wanted to do bowels and and so I said
sure if you want to do balusters wedding
you do Val aesthetic so one of them said
I want to tell you when I decided to
marry you
one night you fell asleep first you
always fall asleep first and I was
looking at you and I started to cry and
I woke you up and you said what and I
said you have to promise me that I'll
die first because I can't stand the idea
of being in this world without you and
you look at me with just infinite
tenderness and you said I promise and
then you fell right back asleep but at
that moment I decided I wanted to marry
you and when he said that first of all
it was not a dry eye in the house and I
thought anybody who would witness this
moment and say this is an abomination ah
I have known I have a very hard time
with yeah so all right so then so you
make this decision now that strikes me
also is somewhat unique because
you don't have to clear that with anyone
right like the conservative might know
it has regular conservative movement
does not right the conservative movement
has the latitude some do and some don't
but they knew yeah and I let my
congregation I let the key people my
congregation know that I was going to do
this but I didn't ask their permission
yeah what do you mean some do and some
don't meaning another I'm conservative
rabbis will do gay marriages and some
well oh so there isn't something like
written in the right now the guys like a
party platform so there is right there
is there is a committee of law and
standards but they basically said you
know you're going to have to make this
decision on your own yeah
did you go to fine council with some
other rabbis and others I read a lot of
what was written about it but I knew
that I wanted to do it I mean I didn't
my question was tactical my question was
how do I do this with minimum damage to
my community because what had happened
to me was several years before a young
man who was gay came to me and said why
won't you do gay marriages and I said
I'm going to give you an answer but you
won't like it I said but here's the
truth I want to I said but I sort of
feel if you'll forgive the grandiosity
of the analogy I feel like Abraham
Lincoln did at the beginning of the
Civil War which is you don't issue the
Emancipation Proclamation before you're
ready I said if I do it now it's going
to tear my community apart I said I have
to wait until they're ready
it'll still be a big thing but it won't
tear them apart because I'm the rabbi of
a community that wasn't good enough for
him I completely understand that yeah
but that was my job we ever able to
reconcile that with him yes really yeah
I came back to him and I said this is
why I and I I don't know I don't know he
still would've preferred I'm sure that I
had done it years before but at least I
did it and also I think he was pleased
at how big a splash it made because that
made him feel proud yeah you know what
kind of that question you get I had a
lot of people who threatened to resign
although only a couple did and at least
of a couple who did one came back I got
a lot of really not nice letters attacks
one of which I shared with you some
private some public and and also put the
artist part really the hardest part was
that I hurt people that I really care
about because there were people who are
like good people and kind people and and
they and they identify with their rabbi
and they can't how could you do this
that's how I felt was like how could you
possibly do this yeah but I told my
daughter again to return to my daughter
during the Boer War Churchill said it's
exhilarating to be shot at without
result and I said to her I said there
the lesson here is if you really believe
in something the people who love you
will still love you and and sooner or
later the world will move on and you
will have the satisfaction of having
done what you know what you know is
right and and you'll survive so it was
in that sense it was it was a beautiful
experience even it was a hard one how do
you navigate those other political
pieces because I'm sure there's a
constant battle between trying to remain
yeah its money rule and and also what a
clergyman is legally allowed to do well
there are political few but there's
different kinds of political pieces I
mean there's politics in the synagogue
itself and then I actually rotationally
write columns for time online and I
wrote a column against repealing the
Johnson amendment the Johnson amendment
is the one where you shouldn't do I
don't think rabbi should endorse
candidates I think that that's a mistake
and you shouldn't ask them to because
then you're going to have the Republican
show in the Democratic show and that's
not good yeah but my basic political
orientation is I will be a firm
supporter of Israel from the pulpit and
any other venue I can but am I going to
take a position as a rabbi on taxes no
am I going to take a position on on most
political issues I think that it's not
my I will do it
interpersonally you asked me personally
I will tell you but as a rabbi I think I
only got to take a position on things
that are clearly of Jewish where I think
the Judaism speaks fairly univocal II on
them you know do you get pushed into
sometimes having to talk about things
that you don't have yes I do sometimes
which okay that's fair I mean this it's
not as though
so it's not as though you don't have a
community and they don't have a say
sometimes they have a say too you know
and they say we really want you to talk
about this and tell us what you think
when I gave I told you I gave the the
invocation at the at the Democratic
National Committee a lot of my
congregation was very upset at that I
said to them listen if the Republicans
had asked me I would have done that I
said I think if a major political party
asks you to give a blessing as a clergy
you give a blessing so in fact the next
month or two months later they had a big
Republican Jewish dinner and they said
okay come give the invocation I said
sure
let me others do and I ran I did it but
but there's an example of like they had
a clear say and they were right to say I
don't want my rabbi to be a Democrat or
a Republican I wanted to be a rabbi yeah
when I've talked to a few people on this
but Dennis Prager particularly talked
about sort of the judeo-christian roots
or a United States and that that we need
those I was basically arguing that if we
were just being governed by the
Constitution if we could just follow the
words of a document that would be enough
for the civil pluralistic society that
we want and he basically was saying that
no we need to stay rooted in this
judeo-christian idea does that well I
wonder I am not enough of a
constitutional scholar to answer this
question adequately but I wonder if you
could make the argument that the
Constitution was in fact rooted in that
judeo-christian idea and there's a sort
of dovetailing of your to our or so I
think that that's sort of where we ended
up leading is that there's enough of it
sort of in the framing right of what we
went with with the Constitution I mean
that all men are created equal that they
are endowed by their creator I mean
that's the Bill of Rights but still yeah
but there's some yeah some stuff in
there I feel like there's so much more
we could talk about you know we'll
circle back to something we some people
that we talk about the beginning so you
mentioned that you you've debated Tim
Harrison as Christopher Hitchens and
Richard Dawkins some of some of my
favorite people and you know Prager and
Shapiro and a couple other people do you
think we're losing the ability to do
this now this wasn't a debate what we
did here right I really wanted to hear
what you saw what about these things but
just the general
of sitting down with people and being
okay with some ideas that you would
agree with or disagree I think what what
I think what we are losing to some
extent some of the people not all some
of the people that you mentioned there
are perfectly willing to sit down and
talk with people who differ with them
what I think that they're not always
willing to do is to be prepared that
their ideas might change and and part of
the reason that that's so is because
even though many people won't say it I
know this is a rabbi you get captured by
your own constituency and what happens
is if someone who has a presence on TV
or radio or whatever if they say
something that's different from what
they've been saying before because
they've changed their mind they will get
a gigantic onslaught from the people by
the way who they like and who are their
followers and who are their supporters
and they'll say how just as I I
mentioned with gay marriage how could
you do this to me that you always said
this and now you're saying that so
there's a hardening and part of the
hardening is not the hardening of the
person only it's a hardening of the
constituency behind the person so that's
that's a tough one that is a tough one
I mean I had this experience sometimes
when I would debate the god stuff and I
felt like the person and I'm sure was
true of me although I like to think not
as much the person on the other side
would make a concession to this argument
or that argument but they letting down
the home team mm-hmm so they didn't
that's sort of the hardest thing to do
hard thing to do
yeah I a couple weeks ago when that
whole bill o'reilly thing happened where
I was getting fired
I tweeted out something to the effect of
I said I don't know the specifics of
what he did but the fact that we revel
in such public destruction of tribal I
think is dangerous yes and the tweet
took off but I also was getting an
insane amount of hate or and then
someone found it somebody searched a
tweet of mine from I think 2011 and
found a tweet where I where I was sort
of reveling in Keith Olbermann and one
it's non-firing Brian governor and they
sent it to me and they said see you see
you hypocrite and I normally don't
respond to people that are coming after
me but I just wrote yes I can see right
here well I can I thought just that and
then I got a lot of accolades for that
but I thought this is so dangerous this
way of thinking that if you thought
something once you can't you can't
change it and also I'm I'm not a big
advocate of the charge of hypocrisy I
really prefer the charge of imperfection
because the truth is yes I know a lot of
people for example who defend
traditional marriage and they've been
married five times and you say to them
they're hypocrites but the answer is no
part of it is you can believe something
and really think that it's good and
still either not be able to live up to
it or be disappointed in yourself I
really I am if you think of imperfection
then it gives people more latitude to
change and more latitude to admit that
they did something shouldn't have done
if you're constantly ready to pounce it
freezes people into positions that I
think are unhelpful so it's so
interesting because you say that and a
few other things you said they strike me
as very not religious things now I
understand I understand your phrasing my
point is where they are directly
religion oh I understand and that's so
so you're framing them with it within
your understanding here's my she here's
my basic my basical would would hear
that laughing about being able to change
and evolve and accept this and that is
just not and what I would say is
repentance and admitting what you've
done wrong and the realization that all
human beings are flawed that's the heart
of the religious tradition and this idea
that you have to jump on someone
whenever they do something that's bad
that that to me is antithetical to the
tradition that I was raised in certainly
so all right so one more for you now
about a half hour ago was it during the
break you we took a 10-second break you
said I think it was on air you said that
you could beat brigitte sending i should
give me a great fact she gave me a great
five minute ending on freedom and
liberty
and Western values and individualism and
all of this stuff so give me some great
piece of Jewish wisdom for people that
are just trying to find a little a
little peace in the universe these days
because I think that that's what people
out being looking for it without being
competitive with I understand why we
love you which I would not do it cuz I
see you know Rashid and I are our
friends and I would not be them to I'm
fighting this directly to Brigitte good
this is what I would say what people
have to realize is the power that they
have to change other people's lives in
an instant because all of your viewers
and all of your listeners know that
people have said things or done things
that change their life even though they
never go back and tell them you know
that to the third grade teacher who said
this I never forgot it and it changed my
life and that realization that people
can change and change each other is is
crucial it's pivotal and it's powerful
and I will close with a story that
illustrates it so there was a rabbi
Govinda good thing to do it's a very
rabbinical pivotal and hair goes to one
of my favorite stories so there was a
rabbi who used to travel around the
world and he would sing and play music
and his name was [ __ ] Carlebach he was
in his time very well known I used to
live on the Upper West there you go what
are you know Crowell dr. gehlbach
synagogue there's a Krell Abbas Seneca
so once after the collapse of the Soviet
Union he went to Eastern Europe and he
was playing in the small community in
the former Soviet Union and he had the
experience where everybody was cold to
him they all like closed the door either
literally or metaphorically in his face
except for one guy and he spent all of
Shabbat all the Sabbath there and at the
end of it before he left he said to this
guy he said listen I understand why
these people don't want to hear from me
I know that they went through you know
the the Second World War and then the
the jackboot of communism and with the
fall of the Soviet Union more things and
then they have shortages and and winter
he says what I don't understand I don't
understand you
he says why are you so opening and why
are you so loving and why are you so
welcoming why are you so different and
the man said I can tell you
exactly why and I'll tell you when it
happened look he said I'm an old man and
I have lived in this town my entire life
and I remember before the first world
war it was the dead of winter and a
rumor swept through the town that the
Cossacks were coming and they were going
to loot and pillage and burn and destroy
so all the parents from the town
gathered up all the children they
brought us to the rabbi's house and they
ringed around the rabbi's house all
night long and he walked up and down
between the rooms where all the children
slept and I was curled up in a corner of
the rabbi's study but I couldn't sleep
because it was bitter cold and in the
middle of the night the rabbi came up
behind me and he took his cloak off his
shoulders and he spread it over me and
he said good child
sweet child you know said the rabbi to
Carlebach it has been almost 80 years
since the rabbi spread his coat on me
but it still keeps me warm those sorts
of moments they're not just nice they're
sacred
their religious moments you can do them
for someone else in an instant almost
every day and many years from now even
though you might not know it it will
still keep them warm or thank you much
for Jeanne that Biggi day rabbi lovely
it's been an absolute pleasure thank you
and for more on Rabbi Wolfie well you
can find him at Sinai temple in Los
Angeles and follow him on twitter at
rabbi Wolfie
thanks
[Music]
you